a new push to help tackle the issue of
kids on dirt bikes creating safety
concerns at parks in a south valley
neighborhood fact that we first showed
you the story last month sally jaramillo
is live near mountains edge parkway in
buffalo where it is windy today with
that new effort to keep people safe
sally
yet denise neighbors living in this area
say they had enough of these dirt bikes
that's why metro police along with clark
county commissioner justin jones are
working together to create change
commissioner justin jones tells me
they've had a lot of complaints about
dirt bikes at the regional park at
mountain's edge he says people are
scared and have been threatened by dirt
bike riders commissioner jones reminds
the community that dirt bikes on county
property and blm land are illegal this
is an area for kids and families to hang
out
to recreate and we don't need people who
are going to be going 40 50 miles an
hour
and really endangering our families in
mountains edge jones says they have park
police patrolling as well as officers
from enterprise area command
back out live law enforcement will cite
you if you're caught riding these dirt
bikes in these parks and depending on
the circumstances you can even fail face
some jail time as well reporting live
from mountaintech sally garamillo live
local now